Speaker 1: Today we're going to be speaking with
Professor Baruch Fischhoff, who is a professor
at Carnegie Mellon University, where he studies
how experts and non-experts think about risks.
It's really great to have you
on. I appreciate your time today.
Speaker 5: Thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: So risk is a very
interesting topic because much
like this is a bad analogy,
but much like when we come across a yellow
light when driving and we are intuitively
making a number of calculations that make us
decide to either go through the light or not.
We are thinking about the risks to us of all
sorts of different activities all the time. And
the first part I think maybe that would make sense
to start with is our human intuition, intuitions
about risk, generally reliable or or not so much
where we have to sometimes step back and say,
am I actually evaluating this risk correctly?
Speaker 5: Well, we're generally pretty good,
particularly where we have good sources
of information or we have the same risk,
see the same risk time and again and have a chance
for trial, trial and error. But when something is
new and we don't have unreliable sources and we
can, you know, we can be in trouble. So I would
say, for example, Pittsburgh is has a driving
culture where people run the reds. I grew up in
Detroit where people are much more drivers
are much more disciplined. And so if I had
a well-tuned intuition for Detroit,
driving took me a while to get right
to to adjust them for Pittsburgh driving.
Speaker 1: So one line that's often repeated for
people who are afraid of flying in on commercial
aviation is, you know, it's really safe.
It's actually more dangerous to drive to the
airport statistically than the flight itself.
And then when you investigate that, you find out
that, well, yes, that's that's true in a way. But
what it's looking at is based on passenger miles.
And because airplanes are much faster than cars,
you're traveling many more miles. And maybe
it's true, but the risk difference is not as
big as some might say with something like that.
How is how is the average human to use that
to assess, is flying safe enough for me?
Because most of us don't think about, well,
what's my risk of dying per thousand miles
driven? We just sort of have a sense of,
do I know people who have died in car accidents?
Could I get into a car accident and survive? And
most of us make the decision that we're willing
to drive around. But are those comparisons useful?
Speaker 5: Not really. I think just for the reason
that you that you cited is that often people
who give us those comparative risk statistics
are really they're trying to work us. They're
trying to get us to do something like like fly
or drive or, you know, wear a mask or wash our
hands or or whatever. It's it's difficult
to find often difficult to find statistics
that are just presented in a trustworthy way, that
aren't slanted, that are really relevant to our
to our our our decisions. And and in situations
like that, where really we depend on people to,
you know, to do that work for us as a report
this morning of some of the things that I wear,
a mask still, this is now May 8th, May 19th,
2022. And that's because I think there's a lot
of uncertainty about long COVID. And there was
a long report, I think, by well-meaning people
with a long report, one of our major newspapers
about it, about a study showing that long COVID
is very common among relatively young people.
But what they didn't tell us is, well, how good
is the measurement of non lung long COVID? Are
the observations for people who've gotten it
from on the ground or the earlier variants where
where the problems were much greater? And how many
people did they have in each group? Like in the
data set that they had? There were relatively
few people over 65, 65, and but that seems
to be because they just didn't have a lot of
observations from people over 65. So it didn't
didn't answer my question. What's the chance of my
getting long COVID if I you know, if I'm exposed
and it certainly didn't answer the question of,
well, if I get long COVID, what's the chance I'm
going to it and get COVID Long-Covid I'm going to
give it to my way for being or just somebody
else. So that's what we really count on the
experts to work up the data in an honest way for
us. So it turns out to be it requires some skill.
Speaker 1: With also presenting the data in a
way that it's sort of useful to people. Seems
like it's a skill as well. I recently read whether
this is accurate or not, it doesn't really matter,
but I recently read that for someone without
preexisting conditions, the risk of dying from
COVID is the same as dying in a car accident for
10,000 miles driven. And I was thinking to myself,
Is that high or low? I don't really know what
that is. It's it's sort of a strange comparison
to make. How do I even evaluate that?
Speaker 5: Yeah. Yeah. And in addition,
you're making your risks and benefits are
different than the to two situation. You
get some benefit from taking a long trip.
You have a different set of benefits from,
you know, from, you know, making a statement or
having to fight to be the person who's wearing a
who's wearing it, wearing a mask. You really want
something. What you really would like is somebody
just to give you the numbers to say, you know, if
you if you take this trip, you have one chance,
an average car trip. I think you have about one
chance in 10 million of being in a fatal accident.
And the risk is even smaller if you're not
drinking or driving early Sunday. So give
me the numbers. People can handle those numbers
and let me decide. Don't. Don't try to work me.
Speaker 1: Can you talk a little bit
about when we measure risk, the difference
between absolute and relative risks.
Speaker 5: Right. So so something can
double your risk of of of, you know,
something terrible happening to you.
But it makes a big difference whether that takes
it from one in 1000000 to 2 in a million or from
one in 100 to 2 and a hundred. So you really need
the absolute numbers, the absolute risk numbers in
order to make the risk benefit tradeoffs, because
you're trading absolute benefits against absolute,
absolute risk. So those those relative risks are
really meaningless. They're often misleading.
Speaker 1: So one example would be in medical
science reporting, we often will read that
a certain food, for example, might increase the
risk or decrease the risk of, say, you know,
a type of cancer by 40%. And that's a very big
number, 40%. But what you're saying is it might
be the difference between a lifetime risk of 1%
and 1.4%. And we need to have that information
to really accurately assess what it means.
Speaker 5: Exactly as some friends or colleagues
at the Dartmouth Medical School who have developed
a drug fact box like the nutrition fact box that
shows you the probability of things going right,
thing going wrong if you take different drugs
and absolute, absolute statistics. And that's
information that even hard for doctors to know
what are examples is is is a sleeping
pill and that you find that people who
take the sleeping pill fall asleep in 37 minutes
compared to people don't take the sleeping pill
fall asleep on average in 45 minutes. And then
they tell you what are the in absolute numbers,
what are the the side effects with or without
the the safety of that? That's what you need to
know. And you and I might make those 8 minutes
might mean a lot to me and not a lot to you
relative to the to the side effects.
Speaker 1: One of the recent ones,
speaking of medications and side effects, has been
around COVID vaccines, where there seem to be some
strange risks. I call them strange. I'll see
if you agree. Strange risk assessments when it
comes to risks of the vaccine specifically as
compared to risks of COVID. So, for example,
when you considered at one point myocarditis
was one topic that that was quite present
and there was a lot of talk of the
risk of myocarditis from the vaccine.
And absent from many of those conversations was
the relative relatively higher risk of myocarditis
from COVID. And very often it seemed like the
consideration people were making was what's my
risk of myocarditis from the vaccine versus zero,
when really it should be compared to the risk from
myocarditis, from COVID, should it not?
Speaker 5: Oh, exactly. And it is it is
a persistent puzzle why people who are very
dedicated to our public health, people who
are very dedicated to our health and our safety
and why they don't know that. And I think I think
it's I mean, I have a lot of respect for public
health. People have dedicated their often brave.
They expose themselves. They work long hours.
Yeah, but I think they don't. They lack three.
They get into these problems three things. One
is they don't know how to do risk analysis. The
second is that their inclination is to tell people
what to do rather than to empower people to make
their own decisions. And the third is they never
test their messages. And if you think we've got a,
you know, wonderfully heterogeneous country where
people have different backgrounds and different
different desires, you can't imagine a technical
expert can't assume that what makes sense to them
will make sense to the people that they're
talking to. And it is easy to test your
messages and draft the message. Let a few
diverse people look at the message, read it,
read it aloud, tell you whatever comes into
their mind, and you're always surprised by
things you thought were clear that confused
them, things that didn't confuse them, but
they misinterpreted things that that you forgot
to say that you thought were common knowledge
and things about your tone, that they found
disrespectful where you thought was good. I
thought it was fine. But you take them off, though
it's easy to test messages, they rarely do it.
Speaker 1: One of the things that relates to
risk assessments I'm reminded of when years
ago I read the book Thinking Fast and Slow, by
Daniel Kahneman, and he talks about a lot of
cognitive biases and heuristics that affect our
thinking about things. And some of them that seem
very relevant to risk assessment would be, for
example, a framing things as the possibilities
of losses versus the possibilities of gains.
He did some very interesting work wherein
he would sort of set up like lottery type
experiments, where in sum there is a probability
of a gain in others, a probability of a loss. But
the expected values, just thinking mathematically
of these scenarios were absolutely identical
in principle. Humans rationally thinking,
should be indifferent between these scenarios. But
we found out that framing things as losses versus
gains had a major impact on people's willingness
to take risks in sort of gambling type situations.
Can you talk a little bit about real
world scenarios, not imaginary lotteries,
but real world scenarios where that cognitive
bias has a real impact on people's decisions?
Speaker 5: So that's an economist who's
one of my doctoral advisors on our way
along with analyst Ski is in his late. Late. Yeah.
So I even have a cameo role in that. Well in the
in the in the in the book. So one thing to know
about the kind of research that that psychologists
do is we look at situations where people have not
figured out what to do. And those are situations
that, from a scientific perspective, are revealing
a fundamental thought of cognitive processes,
emotional processes, where in everyday
life those situations can be fairly rare.
That is, you've learned what to do by trial and
error. Somebody you trust has told you what to,
has told you what, what, what to do. You watch
what other people do and they seem to be getting
along with things and and so on. So. So the
research tends to accentuate the negative
look for problems and the that just the
way our science science goes. Think of
situations like the pandemic put us in
a situation where we don't really know,
you know, where we put us in the situations
where these kinds of biases or framing effects
are most effective because we don't really know
what to do. We don't really know who to trust,
people we thought to have all sorts of different,
different, different ideas. And, you know,
one bit of advice is to talk to different people.
And and they may none of them may know the right
answer, but they will they have different ways of
looking at the problem. And you can decide, well,
what way do I want to frame it? Do I want to be
thinking about this as a loss or a loss or a gain?
Another thing, a bit of advice. I think that the
literature would I think support is don't beat
yourself up too much. Yes, these are legitimately
difficult decisions, partly because they're novel
and the stakes are high, but partly because the
experts have failed us. They haven't given us
statistics that they want. They've manipulated
the statistics, as you know, as you suggested,
as you suggested earlier. So we're really
need a sort of on our on our own. So,
you know, they find somebody you people
you trust run it by a few other people.
If you've done the best you can, then. Things
don't work out. Don't add the insult of regret
to the injury that you've already suffered.
Speaker 1: One really difficult area when it comes
to taking a risk assessment and making policy
and economic decisions is really unlikely events
with an absolutely catastrophic impact. Where
are standard expected value type calculations
might not be very informative. One such would
be, you know, the the the number that's often
stated is the odds of a meteor with at least a
one kilometer diameter hitting earth is basically
one every 500,000 years is when we would
expect that now that could be in two years,
although maybe astronomy is good enough that
we would know if it would be in two years,
but in theory it could be in two years, or
it could be in 499,998 years. So in such a
situation where it's a very low likelihood but
absolutely catastrophic, it can be difficult
to know how much money should be invested in
technology to save us from that. Should we how
much should we invest in the technology that would
allow us to redirect or blow up such a meteor? How
how can humans think about things on that
scale? So catastrophic but so unlikely?
Speaker 5: I mean, one thing the one thing
to ask is, well, well, what? What would we
get for our money? Sure. Great ideas for what to
do about it, then. It's a it's a poor investment
in our own lives. If we can't do anything
about it, why, why? Why worry about it? So
sometimes it pays to worry about relatively small
risks. If we can do something to reduce them or
can put ourselves in the situation where
we're feel like I've done everything I
could and I'm just going to hope for the best.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I guess the difficulty
is, again, if we when we start to get to such
large numbers, it's sort of like thinking about
a billion years ago and that's very hard for most.
You know, some of these the scale of some of these
things is hard for the average human to sort
of think of or, you know, $1,000,000,000,000.
What does that really mean relative to the
average, average annual budget? If you if
you were to shrink it down, there's probably
some very small risk when anyone drives a car,
not of a car accident, but I'm talking about a
mechanical failure that undetected would almost
certainly explode your car and you could make
the decision to check that thing every time
you drive. But none of us really do because we've
assessed the risk is so small. It is that a better
example to think through how we would evaluate
whether action or inaction is the right path?
Speaker 5: Yeah, there's nothing you can do. Don't
worry about it. So some are reasonably safe advice
that if you're really worried about leaving the
gas on, take a picture of your burners before
you leave the house.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
Speaker 5: So there's something you could do.
It doesn't, right? Change the risk in case
they were a little ajar. But it does put your
mind at ease. You, you know, with modern cars,
you can't really look under the hood and figure
out whether everything, anything is going wrong.
You would be fortunate if you're in a state like
Pennsylvania that has mandatory safety checks
every every year and doing it. We've been here
35 years and every few years they find something
that they wouldn't have known of otherwise.
So there's a place where I think, you know,
I think government coercion, as some people
would call it, historic, has served us well.
Speaker 1: Very interesting. We've been
speaking with Professor Baruch Fischhoff,
who teaches at Carnegie Mellon University. Really
appreciate your time and your insights today.
Speaker 5: Oh, thanks.
Thanks for the conversation.